les critiques de la cour des comptes on
en débat tout de suite dans ce sens
public et vous présente mes invités
marie estelle pech bonjour bien joué
vous êtes rédactrice en chef à marianne
spécialiste des questions d'éducation
sophie veneti t'aimons soir bienvenue à
vous aussi vous êtes secrétaire générale
du snes fsu guillaume prévost bonsoir
général de vers le haut c'est un think
tank dédié à la jeunesse et à
l'éducation et qui publie d'ailleurs ce
think tank changer l'éducation c'est
possible voilà on le voit s'afficher
ouvrage collectif et puis avec nous en
duplex ilana cicurel qui est porte
parole de la république en marge des
national en charge de l'éducation de la
formation de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi laetitia que pas toujours à mes
côtés je rappelle on l'a vu un mail le
chiffre peut être le plus frappant de ce
rapport de la cour des comptes les
heures d'absence courte 2 millions 500
mille heures perdues et une sur cinq
remplacer
sophie venez titre et vous dites que la
cour des comptes est déconnecté de la
réalité mais est ce que vous vous
contredisez ou pas ces chiffres déjà
pour commencer déconnectés de la réalité
pas forcément sur le constat mais plutôt
sur les propositions qu'on a même fait
pour faire face à ce constat puisque
finalement la cour des comptes a proposé
des choses comme la bivalence c'est à
dire qu'un professeur enseigne de
discipline mais surtout une des mesures
qu'elle a d'ailleurs recycler un c'est
de dire il faudrait pouvoir à l'inter
d'un collègue vous grandissez quasiment
au pied levé pouvoir remplacer un
professeur qui part en formation un
professeur qui est absent ça
concrètement quiconque a déjà mis un
pied dans un collège ou un lycée s'est
fait ce n'est pas possible et que
surtout que ce n'est pas positif d'un
point de vue pédagogique pour les élèves
alors on reviendra sur les propositions
et sur les solutions mais sur le constat
comment comment c'est possible tout
simplement tout simplement parce qu'en
tant qu'enseignant on est amené à se
former c'est à dire qu'on a passé un
concours mais après on se former tout au
long de notre carrière et quand on se
forme c'est aussi dans l'intérêt des
élèves c'est à dire qu'on va actualiser
nos connaissances on va par exemple
s'approprier aussi de nouvelles
techniques comme le numérique et donc on
se forme avec l'institution sur nos
temps de travail il faut savoir quand se
forme aussi parfois en dehors de nos
temps de service ter qu'on est déjà
amené par des lectures ou autre à
continuer à se former mais il faut bien
avoir en tête que cette formation elle
est quelque part indispensable et elle
se fait sur notre sur notre temps de
service parce que finalement c'est c'est
un acte qui est absolument
incontournable alors l'une et l'autre
comment vous analysé ce constat de la
cour des comptes maria clp ce constat il
effectivement il n'est pas surprenant ce
qui est plus surprenant c'est le sait le
fait surtout que ce chiffre est en
progression je sais ce chiffre de 10%
d'un perdu il est en progression de 24%
entre 2019 et 2020 si je me souviens
bien donc ces essais on voit bien que
les choses ne s'améliorent pas de ces
rapports finalement sur les absences des
enseignants on en a eu plein la part de
la cour des comptes c'est loin d'être le
premier et s qui est ce qui est terrible
c'est de constater que d'abord les
parents et ça le seul la cour des
comptes souligne les parents supportent
de moins - ces absences d'enseignants et
les élèves aussi s'enfonçant font l'écho
sur les réseaux sociaux on à la prof de
maths qui est encore absente en trois
semaines pas de remplacement les
associations de parents d'élèves elles
tiennent des comptes maintenant assez
précis sur des sur des sites internet
elle elle comptabilise et effectivement
si c'est assez colossal on peut
considérer que dans certaines dans
certains départements certaines régions
surtout en ile de france en
seine-saint-denis où on a un manque
d'enseignants on peut avoir jusqu'à un
an de scolarité perdu pourra pour un
élève sur l'ensemble d'une scolarité
donc c'est vraiment énorme après les
constats donc on les connaît depuis
longtemps qu'est ce qu'on fait pour y
remédier et ben moi j'ai envie de dire
pas grand chose quand même parce que
que propose la cour des comptes elle
prouve dit l'essentiel de ces absences
sont liés comme le dit madame bénédicte
et à aux absences liées à la formation
continue donc il faudrait que la
pourquoi parce que la formation continue
se passe pendant les heures de cours des
élèves 1 et ne se passe pas pendant les
absences des élèves c'était parce que la
peau est quoi le mercredi ça pourrait
être le mercredi où ça se figeait
mercredi ça pourrait être ça pourrait
être pendant une partie des vacances
scolaires des élèves parce qu'il faut
quand même rappeler que les professeurs
ne sont pas censés être en vacances
pendant les vacances scolaires ce sont
les élèves qui sont en vacances les
professeurs continuent à travailler ils
n'ont ils sont censés ils sont ils ont
le même régime que leurs aises la
fonction publique ils sont environ à 5
semaines de cinq semaines de vacances
par an donc on peut se demander pourquoi
une partie de ces semaines ne sont pas
sacraliser pour faire de la formation
éviter c'est éviter ces absences j'ai
évidemment vous vous proposer de
répondre à cet aspect mais sur sur la
formation la guillaume prévost et si je
ne me trompe ça a été mis en place en
tout cas proposé par le ministre jean
michel blanquer aqua ya deux ans le fait
de pouvoir se former en dehors des
deux classes alors la formation des
enseignants identifiées depuis longtemps
jean michel blanquer comme un
levier très important de la réussite des
élèves et de la progression des
enseignants tout au long de leur
carrière c'est vrai dans l'éducation
nationale c'est vrai dans l'ensemble des
métiers on est face à un enjeu très
important de formation continue sur
l'ensemble des professions c'est parti
c'est normalement auraient dans
l'éducation de ce point de vue là moi
j'insiste e rey sur une autre dimension
des chiffres qui sont révélées par la
cour des comptes c'est que aujourd'hui à
20% des absences des enseignants qui
sont dus à cette formation
professionnelle continue et là il ya un
vrai sujet à de notre point de vue mieux
objective et l'ensemble des tâches des
enseignants aujourd'hui les textes
réglementaires ne rendent pas compte de
l'ensemble des tâches qui des missions
des enseignants et sont trop seulement
focalisé sur le temps passé devant la
classe on sait bien comme vous l'avez
dit n'importe quelle personne qui va
dans un établissement c'est bien que
parmi les missions des enseignants il ya
la relation avec les parents d'élèves le
travail pédagogique collectif
évidemment les corrections la formation
donc deux points de vue il est urgent
pour objectiver le débat notamment au
moment où s'ouvre le débat sur l'école
dans cette campagne présidentielle que
l'on se donne la peine de mieux
objectiver le temps est filmé est d'être
arrivé à ce qu'ils soient l'âge ou perd
un peu pour être pour être honnête votre
position c'est quoi ces il faut quelques
profs se forme aussi le mercredi et
pendant les vacances scolaires des
enfants il faut que le professeur ce il
faut que les professeurs se forme il ya
des propositions très intéressantes dans
la cour des comptes de ce qu'ont dû là
notamment dans le cadre de parcours de
formation on n'est pas obligé de
découvrir du mercredi pour le jeudi qu
on a une formation non non on peut aussi
en début d'année avoir un parcours de
formation intégré son emploi du temps et
qui permettent à la fois de donner c'est
15 18 heures de cours devant élèves et
de se former tout au long de l'année
comme on le fait dans d'autres
professions ça peut surtout s'anticiper
effectivement cercle partir du moment où
un professeur on sait qu'il va partir
trois jours pour une formation les
enseignants devraient pouvoir en interne
anticipé et s'auto se remplacer les uns
les autres dire ben moi je serai absent
à tel moment et d'ailleurs ça marche
dans certains établissements scolaires
faut pas qu'on peut pas dire que tous
nos tout ne fonctionne là on a des chefs
d'établissement et des enseignants qui
sont de bonne volonté et qui alors il
s'agit pas de dire que tout est
remplaçable parce que c'est pas vrai
l'enseignant qui est malade du jour on
en a on va pas pour le remplacer comme
ça au pied levé
celle qui est en congé en congé de
maladie
[Musique]
maternité ça s'anticipe d'une autre
façon parce que c'est une absence longue
mais une petite absence de trois jours
alors madame bénédicte et dick d'un
point de vue pédagogique ce n'est pas
souhaitable moi je pense que c'est quand
même plus davantage souhaitable pour un
élève d'avoir un autre professeur qui
est pas forcément préparé qui est pas
forcément exactement dans la même
méthode pédagogique que l'autre en que
l'enseignant quand elle sent que rien
que d'être à l'étude et à ne rien faire
alors je vais le mettre les pieds dans
le plat je viens d'apprendre quelque
chose que les professeurs n'étaient pas
en vacances pendant que les élèves
étaient en vacances je vous l'assuré
sais pas je ne fais pas ça avec un
mauvais esprit c'est je suis absolument
sincère je pensais que les professeurs
étaient en vacances dans que font les
professeurs s qui travaillent pas mais
comment est-ce que ces contrôles et
qu'est-ce qu'ils font alors ce n'est pas
contrôlée mais il travaille pendant les
vagues au moins une partie du temps du
temps d'absence du temps de scolaire des
élèves ils travaillent ils préparent
leur cours il corrige les copies il
travaille aussi pendant les vacances
leur temps de travail ne se résume pas
au fait d'être devant les et la question
nationale souffre pas d'un manque de
transparence en fait sur sophie et il ya
plein d'éléments moi j'aimerais vraiment
qu'on va ce focus sur l'histoire de la
formation bien sûr alors jusqu'à même
sur la question du temps de travail des
enseignants le ministère est très
transparent puisque lui-même produit des
enquêtes où il montre que on travaille
un peu plus de 40 heures par semaine
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
objective et qui est connue de tous et
après pour revenir sur l'action de la
formation vous disiez parce qu'il faut
bien les distinguer des formations un
peu plus longue tout à l'heure vous
parliez des trois semaines de cours
perdus etc ça c'est un autre sujet où
effectivement on manque cruellement de
remplaçant maintenant si je prends
l'exemple de du départ de trois jours en
formation d'une journée en formation
déjà il arrive parfois que ces
formations tombe sur un jour où on n'a
pas forcément courant mais ça m'est déjà
arrivé d'avoir une formation le vendredi
est un jour où je n'ai pas cours donc ça
ça arrive par ailleurs il faut pas
croire que quand on part en formation on
laisse nos élèves comme ça sans rien
leur donner musée vaut mieux un prof qui
sait pas trop ce qu'il va faire plutôt
que laisser les élèves comme ça ban on
est quand même un certain nombre quand
on part en formation une journée ou deux
journées on donne du travail à nos
élèves c'est à dire qu'ils sont dans les
cartons mais ce qui est dingue c'est que
ça se prépare une formation elle doit
j'ai vu dans un dans un calendrier est
donc on devrait pouvoir justement voir
emplacement est très quelqu'un qui tombe
malade c'est difficile de le remplacer
de du jour au lendemain je l'entends
mais une formation qui est prévu six
mois à l'avancé on s'assoit ya pas d r
on s'inscrit suffisamment à l avance
pour pouvoir être pour pouvoir être
formés après est ce que quand même
l'idée que un professeur quasiment du
jour au lendemain dans un établissement
arriverez prendrait une classe sans la
connaître il faut bien savoir ce que
c'est que connaître une classe quand on
est enseignant quand vous débarquez et
que vous me connaissez pas la classe que
vous venez pour aller une ou deux heures
sur deux jours que vous découvrez la
classe l'androïde où ils sont dans le
programme mais
sachant qu'on leur donne du travail
quand on est en formation alors je vous
parle on est con saignante et dire qu'en
tant qu'enseignante et je crois que je
peux en parler de ce point de vue là sur
sur ce plateau c'est que prendre une
classe à l'improviste c'est quand même
le sait c'est sûr vous faites du
présentiel vous affichez aya pas
d'absence il ya un professeur un adulte
devant chaque élève après moi ce que je
vous pose très clairement la question
est ce que le but c'est de faire du
présentiel et de remplir la statistique
y'a pas d'absence ou est ce que le but
c'est d'apporter à l'ordre du jour je
vais me tourner vers ivana cicurel cas
pas encore pris la parole dans ce débat
merci d'être avec nous encore une fois
parce que je dis je disais tout à
l'heure je demandais à guillaume prévost
aussi effectivement sur cette question
de la formation et du fait qu'on propose
aux professeurs aux enseignants de se
former sur un temps qui n'est pas leur
temps de cours habituel ça a été une
proposition de jean michel blanquer il
ya deux ans si je ne me trompe est-ce
que vous avez des éléments des chiffres
sur sa sur son application
d'abord je voulais rappeler
bonsoir à toutes et à tous que il ya
aussi les absences hung et que sur les
intentions on est à un taux de 96 % de
remplacement pour le lycée c'est
important de le rappeler donc il faut
circonscrire la question qu'on traite ce
soir alors les absences courtes qui sont
liées en partie comme ça a été
effectivement
appelé par la cour des comptes à la
formation d'abord il faut se réjouir
comme plusieurs des intervenants ce soir
que les professeurs se forme c'est
extrêmement important c'est sûr là les
les chiffres de la cour des comptes se
fonde en fait sur 2008 18 2019 donc un
certain nombre de mesures que je
voudrais partager avec vous dont on voit
pas encore les effets mais qui vont
totalement changé la donne par exemple
vous avez la possibilité d'avoir deux
heures supplémentaires par dans une
équipe le chef d'établissement est de
plus en plus en mesure de confier donc
avant c'était une heure maintenant c'est
deux heures ça change beaucoup d'heures
supplémentaires pour remplacer un de ses
collègues ensuite vous avez les
directeurs d'école qui acquiert
maintenant une grande autonomie donc ils
pourront davantage s'organiser pour
effectivement anticiper tout cela
troisième élément qui est un élément
très intéressant c'est que la formation
et avec la pandémie ça va encore plus
vite elle est de plus en plus aussi sur
support numérique
donc cette formation elle va pouvoir
s'adapter aussi davantage aux
contraintes des professeurs cet effet on
va le voir progressivement mais il ya
une autre piste que je voudrais partager
avec vous c'est qu'il y a eu un
renforcement de la possibilité c'est
tout à fait nouveau savait qu'en janvier
2022 pour les surveillants les
assistants d'éducation
d'avoir des heures supplémentaires est
davantage présent est de pouvoir donc
adapter si on a besoin d'un assistant
d'éducation pour encadrer une classe
s'il savait très utile parce que ça
arrange aux intéressés c'est très
intéressant je reprends la dylan a
secure et je suis sûr que vous
m'entendez donc je reprends la main vous
avez ouvert des thématiques dont sur
lesquelles on va revenir notamment la
question de l'autonomie des directeurs
d'école qui est très importante mais
vous avez pas du tout répondu à ma
question donc joue là repose est ce que
oui ou non d'appliquer me jean-michel
blanquer a proposé aux enseignants de se
former par exemple sur le le temps des
vacances scolaires est ce que oui ou non
ça se met en place et est ce qu'il ya eu
ou non des professeurs c'est sur la base
du volontariat qui répondent oui on y va
oui je pense que ça se met en place et
je pense que les professeurs sont les
premiers à dire
leur temps de travail il dépasse de loin
le temps de présence face à élèves donc
on comprend très bien que le temps qui
n'est pas devant élèves soient les
petites vacances soit les temps où on
n'a pas cours puissent être utilisés
pour la formation j'ai pas de chiffres à
vous livrer ce soir mais je pense que
effectivement ça c'est en train de se
transformer vous alors on vous redonne
la parole dans un instant mais je ne
change rien pardon il ya un petit
problème technique et je reviens vers
vous vraiment ses premiers la nacip sur
elle pendant le débat vous aurez la
parole plus à plusieurs reprises la cour
des comptes en parlant de cesser ces
formations pendant les vacances
scolaires parce que c'est pas nouveau en
réalité un fourgon delà des enseignants
qui se forment pendant les vacances
scolaires mais c'est extrêmement limité
c'est des gens qui sont très volontaires
etc et le volume total des formations
pendant les petites vacances scolaires
c'est de l'ordre de 1% voilà d'accords
importants du volet de formation peut
pas si j'aurais pensé à ma question ça
ne peut pas être contraignant est
d'ailleurs la mesure qui avait été mise
en place par jean michel blanquer
parce qu'il sait que les enseignants non
c'est logique d'ailleurs ils considèrent
qu'ils sont quand même aussi en vacances
enfin même si ce ne sont pas des
vacances sur un plan un bond en bref ils
sont quand même en vacances ils ont ils
ont un mot qui sont quand même
globalement assez réticents voire très
réticent sur cette cette histoire de
formation pendant les vacances scolaires
dès qu'il a proposées 140 euros je crois
brut d'indemnités par jour de formation
aux enseignants qui acceptent de se
former pendant les vacances scolaires
mais même malgré ça visiblement ça
patine en bio prévaut sur la formation
j'aurais parce que finalement
l'empreinte que deux formations externes
comme si après tout pour se former il
fallait absolument quitter son
établissement mais si on regarde leur
quête thalys de l' ocde qui compare un
peu à la façon pour s'organiser des
écoles dans des différends tail ocde on
se rend compte que l'école française et
l'école où les pratiques coopératives
entre professeurs sont les plus faibles
l'école française et l'école dans
laquelle la part des professeurs qui
vont dans les autres et là ça va un peu
dans le sens de ce que vous disiez qui
vont dans les autres classes voir
comment leurs enseignants se débrouille
avec des élèves qui sont peu ou prou
comparables c'est en france que les
enseignants le fond le moins on est dans
une approche de l'école et de
l'enseignant un peu monolithique face à
sa classe et tout l'enseignement serait
là or il ya un enjeu considérable à
s'inspirer de ce qui fonctionne en
france comme à l'étranger et ce qui
fonctionne c'est le collectif les
pratiques pédagogiques large l'école qui
s'intéresse aux pratiques périscolaire
aux différents temps de l'enfant à la
relation avec les familles et là il ya
un vrai enjeu on a parlé un peu de
objectivation des temps de travail de
l'enseignant et je pense que c'était un
vrai besoin pour l'ensemble des cars
dont moi je comprends pas quand vous
dites ça ça c'est aujourd'hui n'est le
temps de travaux jour du monde inédit
être professeur dans secondaire ces 15
ou 18 heures en fonction de son statut
oui si je suis agrégée ses 15 heures si
je suis certifié je suis à 18h dans le
primaire je dois faire 25 heures et en
plus j'ai 108 heures sur l'année pour
faire tout le reste notre proposition
c'est de dire il faut qu on se rend
mieux compte de ce que ça veut dire on
dit corriger les copies qu'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est combien de la ont dit
exactement on dit parler avec les
parents combien d'heures quels objectifs
est ce qu'on doit voir les parents trois
fois par an deux fois par an une fois
par an et là on pourra rentrer pour de
vrai dans des débats constructifs en
apportant des solutions constructives
visant à donner davantage de grain à
moudre aux acteurs de terrain corps est
pas alors des discussions un peu de cela
est-ce que vous êtes prêts sophie lesne
édité à cette forme de transparence
d'une certaine façon dans dans l'utile
l'utilisation de votre temps de travail
la ventilation de votre activité ouais
c'est absolument pas une question taboue
la transparence on le fait d'ailleurs je
vous en parle assez librement ce soir et
je vous le dis on a effectivement un
temps de travail qui est de plus de 40
heures ce qui est d'ailleurs une place
au dessus des 35 heures de la plupart
des salariés et on a effectivement du
temps devant élèves du temps de
correction alors après le temps de
correction est temps de préparation des
cours il dépend aussi des niveaux il
n'est pas envisagé ils dépendent les
disciplines ouais je vois par exemple
cette année j'ai des classes qui ne
ressemble pas du tout à celle de l'an
dernier et j'ai aussi modifier des
choses dans mon approche avec les élèves
et donc je ne prépare pas les choses de
la même manière c'est pas le même
travail donc ouais mais vous le dis très
clairement aujourd'hui le métier
d'enseignant c'est un métier avec un
temps de travail qui est extrêmement
important c'est d'ailleurs parce que
j'entends beaucoup depuis tout à l'heure
pointé du doigt des enseignants qui
voudraient pas soir et pendant les
vacances qui voudrait pas faire ceci
qu'il faudrait pas faire cela je suis
pas certaine que les solutions par
exemple à la crise d'attractivité très
importante mon bonnet le métier
d'enseignant
soit
à pointer systématiquement du doigt les
soi-disant privilège d des enseignants
donc on est capable de dire ce qu on
travaille on est capable de dire aussi
quels sont nos besoins après
interrogeons-nous aussi sur la
responsabilité de l'institution et pas
seulement des enseignants dans ce qui se
passe parce que j'entendais un certain
nombre de propositions qui ont été
faites ou qui vont être faites par par
jean michel blanquer on est quand même
sur la aussi des solutions qui sont
assez déconnecté de la région m un
milieu professionnel
ultrasensible enfin dire qu'on soit par
an qu'on soit journaliste pense que vous
soyez là sur le plateau vous parler tout
de suite avec de l'émotion vous dites
pointé du doigt c'est factuel ce que
madame bien de dire c'est factuel 1% des
profs qui acceptent de se former pendant
les vacances scolaires on n'est pas en
train de pointer du doigt on est en
droit de vous avez dit tout à l'heure on
vous étonnant qu'on lui souffle pendant
les vacances mais voilà enfin pardon
c'est mon inculture crasse mais je ne
savais pas je vous l'assuré je l'aï noté
et je vous le dis tranquillement jamais
parlé à l'ail aussi pendant les vacances
de façon transparente sans que ça
devienne voilà encore une fois un
terrain émotionnel mais pourquoi
pourquoi on peut pas on a boy a
tranquillement les mre vos points sans
cela on essaie de comprendre pourquoi je
vous entends très 3 son métier qui est
formidable n'attire plus oui les
vocations ccc temps mais il faut quand
il faut défendre probablement un peu les
enseignants la jirs est clairement dans
ce sens là ensuite on si on regarde tout
à l'heure on a parlé de remplacement
d'institutions de comme on gère les
heures supplémentaires la cour des
comptes plat c'est très technique la
question du remplacement des enseignants
des finalement derrière il ya des vraies
personnes et des vraies personnes qui
arrivent devant un établissement à mon
enseignement ma collègue est pas là
comment je fais pour la remplacer il ya
une vraie alors là je voudrais pas
prendre
me faire le porte parole des professeurs
mais une vraie souffrance au travail des
professeurs qui probablement pas assez
pris en compte et de ce point de vue là
il ya quand même il ya quand même un
constat loin de ce que pensent de ce
qu'on peut penser dans le débat public
en fait les arrêts maladie les
professeurs ne sont pas supérieurs à ce
qu'ils sont dans d'autres professions et
sont même légèrement inférieure est ce
qu'ils sont en moyenne dans la fonction
publique la cccd moyenne 7,1 jour dans
la fonction pour les antilles a
probablement aussi des choses qu'on a
beaucoup dit sur les professeurs on a
beaucoup attaqué les professeurs et qui
explique la façon des les professeurs se
sentent obligés de se défendre
dans ce rapport de la cour des comptes
ce que je retiens quand même c'est je
reviens sur cette histoire de deux
formations et d'heures perdues parce que
c'est quand même le sentiment quand on
parents d'élèves ont peu à voir en
disant banon mon enfant il a plu prof
d'espagnol n'a pas de prof de maths
c'est des heures perdues c'est que
l'éducation nationale manque d'outils
fiables pour savoir où sont soupçons
sont effectivement les profs et comment
on peut les remplacer est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça si tu sais c'est
la suggestion effectivement du
remplacement qui est qui pourrait être
sérieusement amélioré il faut pas dire
qu'il ne se passe rien mais je voudrais
quand même revenir sur une chose est ce
qu ont effectivement on parle beaucoup
des enseignants mais l'institution elle
a quand même beaucoup aussi à ceux à
ceux à peut-être à s'interroger sur la
façon dont elles organisent ne serait-ce
que les concours les examens le bac le
brevet tout ça quand on organise le bac
ça bouscule complètement le
fonctionnement des établissements
scolaires les ors dont on parle et on a
les deux tiers qui sont dus au système
éducatif et un tiers liés aux problèmes
de santé ou familiaux des enseignants
oui alors quand vous v le brevet tout
est fermé le collège l'ensemble du col
de san concerne que les élèves de 3e
pour le bac c'est pareil ça affecte
l'ensemble du lycée donc les élèves de
terminale mais aussi de premières
secondes et peut-être même parfois des
collégiens quand il s'agit de cités
scolaires donc là on a des semaines et
des semaines de cours qui s'envolent en
fumée et ça c'est vraiment liées au
fonctionnement intrinsèque de
l'éducation nationale ce n'est pas les
enseignants qui ont responsables ont ce
là dessus et ensuite je vais chercher il
a sécurisé sur la question de
l'organisation sur et notamment des
examens je serai juste remarqué que par
exemple dans la réforme du baccalauréat
là qui va se mettre en place il ya
maintenant des épreuves au mois de mars
donc là par exemple au mois de mars avec
la réforme de jean michel blanquer il va
y avoir trois à quatre jours d'épreuves
en plein milieu du mois de mars et avec
effectivement des établissements qui est
qui qui pourraient être fermées alors
qu'avant dans le précédent bac on était
sur la fin de l'année scolaire quand les
choses aient été joué donc à prévoir si
alors avec qui je voudrais il a amassé
sécurel vous entendra dessus notamment
sur la part du contrôle continu j'ai cru
comprendre quand même que elle devenait
plus important donc ça de vieillesse à
deux ça pourrait régler une partie de
des difficultés évoquées pas apprendre
marié cette pêche à l'instant
oui mais écoutez moi je voudrais qu'on
se ressentent sur l'élève parce que je
crois que ce qui est notre préoccupation
à tous et de se dire qu'à partir du
moment où un enfant est dans la classe
il doit pouvoir recevoir
une un enseignement dans un et je crois
qu'on doit partir de là je crois que
c'est un engagement et on doit évoluer
vers sa gelée dit tout à l'heure la clé
c'est plus de moyens c'est le cas parce
qu'à des heures supplémentaires qui qui
vont être possible de mobiliser chez les
profs ensuite vous avez l'autonomie
c'est très important vous avez directeur
d'école qui aujourd'hui même je vais
mettre ça tu me répéter ce que vous avez
dit nos meilleures clés je faisais moi
je vous ai posé pas moi ça m'arrive
rarement énervé mais je vous ai dans une
question précise sur escaut en plus
elles peuvent être plutôt favorables y
est ce que le contrôle continu ça permet
de réduire le nombre d'heures ou de
jours d'établissements fermés à cause
des à cause des décombres oui bien sûr
du brevet merci de répondre
oui c'est c'est eh oui bien sûr bien sûr
que c'est le cas mais c'est difficile de
participer à un débat quand on est loin
et je moi je voulais partager avec vous
des solutions innovantes qui sont en
train d'être expérimentée si ça vous
intéresse je serais ravi nous enseigne
que vous avez déjà présenté tout à
l'heure les cherche des solutions pour
les élèves ont cherché ou par la voie là
et je crois que on doit on doit partir
on doit trouver des moyens d'avoir plus
d'heures remplaçant ilya mais je crois
que on a découvert aussi avec la
pandémie que le numérique ne pourrait
jamais remplacer le professeur je crois
qu'on s'est tous rendu compte ce qu'ils
n'en tiendraient pas compte que le
professeur il est au coeur de la
transmission et rien ne peut se faire
sans lui maintenant quand vous avez
effectivement il le professeur dé est
très bien tout à l'heure il n'y a rien
de pire que d'arriver devant une classe
qu'on connaît pas et tout d'un coup vers
provenaient quelque chose c'est pas
forcément la meilleure solution et on
est en train de développer pour
justement c ces absences très courte des
modules qui sont pensés par les par des
professeurs est en lien avec
l'inspection qui vont être très adapté à
l'endroit du programme où les enfants
sont avec les élèves avec le professeur
le professeur qui doit s'absenter va
pouvoir dire exactement où il en est et
vous avez la possibilité d'avoir via le
numérique des choses qui sont proposés
pas des vidéos balancer comme ça mais
des choses très adapté et qui permettent
aux professeurs d'avoir un retour sur
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les enfants son
absence et que ce soit optimisé
autrement dit évidemment rien ne peut
remplacer la présence du professeur mais
si on sait moyens numériques sont une
véritable révolution qui vont permettre
dans la continuité de l'enseignement du
professeur
optimiser ces moments où éventuellement
il doit s'éloigner de sa classe et là je
voulais le partager avec vous pour qu'on
ne soit pas simplement en train de
déplorer qu'on avance qu'on progresse et
qu'on n'y est pas encore il ya vraiment
des outils surtout pour ces temps cours
de remplacement ou un professeur soyons
va se former c'est très important qu'ils
se sentent samad en charge de
l'attractivité du métier qu'ils puissent
se former merci beaucoup pardon nous
avons interrompu une nouvelle fois
sophie bénédicte et ça alors réponse
tout de suite sur le numérique en quoi
il faut quand même qu'il ya un adulte
dans la classe j'imagine donc comment ça
pourrait se mettre en place ce module
c'est vrai qu'on si on imagine un module
avec par exemple deux trois exercices à
faire en lien avec le cours avant après
et c'est bon il ya déjà des choses qu'on
peut donner peut-être au format papier
aux élèves pendant notre absence mais
mettons la maintenance et le numérique
il faut forcément à un moment quelqu'un
pour encadrer une classe de me dire on
ne pense que personne autour de cette
table n'imagine line classe en autonomie
la plus totale genlis et on laisse pas
nos classes en autonomie la plus totale
donc ça veut dire et quand même
quelqu'un pour encadrer tout ça
j'entendais parler des surveillants
espérer surveillants qui sont à la vie
scolaire etc savoir qu'aujourd'hui les
surveillants ils ont déjà énormément de
travail dans les établissements
scolaires c'est eux qui surveille la
cantine la grille et c'est en période de
cause ils ont été très très pris par la
surveillance de plein de choses et
aujourd'hui se dire que on va demander
aux surveillants d'en faire encore plus
alors qu'ils sont déjà en fin de vie
scolaire sont en train d'imploser et qui
on va leur demander alors qu'elle est
quelle va être leur place par rapport à
l'enseignant parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
rôle d'un enseignant pour ça laisse
quand même des contours assez flous et
moi me laisse assez perplexe sur la
capacité sur les heures supplémentaires
parce que
ilana cicurel en a parlé deux fois le
fait d'avoir doubler cette capacité
d'utiliser les heures supplémentaires
donc c'est à dire un professeur dans
l'établissement qui va faire les heures
supplémentaires pour remplacer un de ses
collègues absents alors il ya la
deuxième heure supplémentaire dont il
était question c'est une heure
supplémentaire qu'on fait en plus toutes
les semaines dans le cadre de notre
service par exemple je vais prendre deux
heures supplémentaires moi ça me fait
une classe en plus de monde à ça et puis
après il ya l'autre possibilité qui est
de prendre d'avoir une rend plus la
semaine prochaine pour remplacer par
exemple on a collègues dans la halle aux
poissons gervais ça alors c'est deux
choses différentes dans la deuxième
option ils étaient où elle trouve
intéressant mais plus dans le cadre des
remplacements là encore si si ça veut
dire prendre au pied levé une classe
d'un strict point de vue pédagogique et
puisqu'on est là pour parler des élèves
ça peut permettre de bricoler quelque
chose mais c'est pas l'idéal et quant
aux heures supplémentaires de manière
générale pour les pour les enseignants
je voudrais juste rappeler
qu'effectivement ce gouvernement les a
les a augmentées pour les enseignants
mais qu'on touche à la limite humaine de
l'exercice parce qu'en fait toutes les
heures supplémentaires ne sont pas
prises elles ne sont pas consommés parce
qu'en fait on arrive à la lime parce que
des heures supplémentaires c'est des
classes en plus les élèves en plus des
réunions en plus et si on veut bien
faire notre travail un moment on peut
pas enchaîner les les classes et les
élèves dont il ya quand même des limites
à ce qui a été dit à l'est par le temps
qui nous reste dix minutes à lisible
dans le whois simplement ajouté que les
heures supplémentaires de certains
enseignants dont veulent pas simplement
ça peut être par exemple des
enseignantes qui vient d'avoir un bébé
qui on préfère qu'ils m'ont qui ont pas
envie de ce jeu surcharger leurs emplois
du temps vous avez des âges vous avez
envie d'avoir de faire plus d'heures
supplémentaires d'avoir de gagner un peu
plus d'argent d'autres vous en vous
préférez vous préservez donc ça peut pas
être la solution effectivement absolu
sur le port pour résoudre ce problème d
d d absence et puis on parle pas non
plus on n'a pas parlé des absences
longues des absences non remplacées
longue il faut savoir qu'on a des
territoires comme la seine-saint-denis
où qui cumule toutes les difficultés
d'une part et un manque d'attractivité
énorme parce que les difficultés
sociales des enfants il comptait les
sociale en général de la population ils
sont tels que les enseignants n'ont pas
envie d'aller y enseignait donc vous
avez un manque de évidemment des
difficultés à attirer les ondes et les
enseignants donc vous avez évidemment
beaucoup de mal à les remplacer et vous
avez même à l'école primaire alors là
attention on parle pas de collèges et
lycées on parle d'école primaire donc
d'enfants qui peuvent pas garder tout
seul donc l'enfant il est où il ne peut
pas être accueillis dans la classe
parfois pendant pendant des jours voire
des semaines c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement en seine saint denis quand
même avec le co vide en plus on passe à
la sueur 2010 multiplié et vous avez des
femmes et les parents dans une panade
pas possible qu'est ce qu'ils disent à
leur employeur enfin depuis deux ans là
on peut pas en permanence dire excuse
moi je suis désolé je peux pas venir
travailler je peux pas venir travailler
je peux pas venir travailler donc c'est
ça c'est un problème social qui est très
fort on voit les répercussions fortes de
c2c de c2c non-remplacement vous vous
parliez de et on l'a évoqué plusieurs
fois du manque d'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant je propose à steam jourdain
de nous rejoindre parce que
re bonsoir steve
la cour des comptes pointe de ce manque
d'attractivité la fête tombe bien le
sénat s'était emparé cette question oui
c'est un rapport publié il ya trois
semaines est remis par le sénateur l'est
républicain gérard longuet ce rapport
analyse précisément les raisons de ce
manque d'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant et parmi ces raisons il ya
une grille salariale vous en parle et
elle a une grille salariale défavorable
aux enseignants en début de carrière
leur rémunération sont en deçà de la
moyenne européenne selon le cdh et le
salaire des ens des enseignants du
primaire et du secondaire après 10 ou 15
ans est inférieur de -15% on le voit à
l'écran 15 % par rapport à la moyenne de
l'oscd sûrs en parité de pouvoir d'achat
et puis regardez cet autre chiffre
thomas au cours des 20 dernières années
les enseignants français ont par
ailleurs perdu entre 15 et 25% de leur
pouvoir d'achat en euros constants et
puis dernier chiffre important les
salaires des professeurs du public sont
très inférieurs à ceux des actifs du
privé - 23 % à l'école élémentaire
-12% au collège fait quelles sont les
solutions proposées par le sénat une
revalorisation salariale salariales bien
évidemment notamment pour les débuts de
carrière alors cette revalorisation a
été enclenché sous emmanuel macron mais
elle doit se poursuivre à aller plus
loin selon les sénateurs rappelons que
l'année prochaine 726 millions d'euros
de revalorisation sont prévus dans le
budget de l'état et puis autre mesure
proposée par les sénateurs thomas des
recrutements d'enseignants pour
anticiper les évolutions démographiques
ou encore une augmentation du budget
formation des enseignants vous en
parliez là encore tout à l'heure il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui le budget moyen
consacré à la formation continue est de
87 euros annuels par enseignant c'est
trop peu selon les sénateurs c'est en
tout cas insuffisant pour rattraper le
déficit accumulé par la france dans ce
domaine merci beaucoup merci steve pour
c'est pour ces éléments je voudrais
qu'on ouvre un chapitre dans
dans ce débat sur le la question de
l'autonomie ou du pouvoir des directeurs
d'établissements aussi nous reste voilà
vous tient au courant il nous reste sept
minutes donc le temps fit vite ça ton
c'est bon signe le débat est passionnant
est-ce que ça vous semble un élément
central ça guillaume apprend le débat
plus largement au delà des directeurs
d'école on a parlé on parle beaucoup
d'heures supplémentaires ou pas on parle
d'un débat qui est très technique
finalement pour les français et qui
explique la difficulté à mener ce débat
au coeur de la campagne présidentielle
où on a tendance à privilégier des
débats qui sont à mon sens moins
intéressant comment rendre le débat plus
intéressant pour les français je crois
qu'il faut arrêter de parler de choses
trop techniques trop réglementaire qui
correspondent pas au vécu des français
il ya un million professeur en france
tout le monde connaît un instituteur un
professeur des écoles un professeur au
lycée au collège il ya des réalités
humaines derrière en quelle est la
réalité humaine et ce à la cour des
comptes le dis très clairement quarante
ans de réformes successives qui sans
arrêt sont venus donner des coups de
boutoir à la condition enseignante qui
d'ailleurs ont largement consommée les
là les heures de travail consacrée à
l'information sans résultat tangible ni
pour les élèves ni pour les parents ni
pour les enseignants la de ce conduit là
il ya un vrai aggiornamento révolution
copernicienne à opérer sur la condition
enseignante et de ce point de vue là
l'avancé visant à donner plus de marge
de manoeuvre plus de latitudes plus de
pouvoir d'initiative aux acteurs locaux
directeur d'école chef d'établissement
au proviseur
enseignants et même au delà les
éducateurs l'ensemble des éducateurs
dont les clubs sportifs donc la série
déterminante non non pas du tout c'est
pas rien à voir avec le collège unique
par contre ça amène un compris ça amène
alors passez moi pour déconnecter bon
pour en parler ça amène à se poser la
question
de comment donner la capacité à chacun
de véritablement endosser pleinement sa
fonction est pleinement mener à bien des
projets donc ça veut dire que le
directeur d'établissement il pourrait
avoir quoi des pouvoirs un peu de
de rh une certaine tension drh ou alors
la vie des enseignants je trouve que rh
c'est très intéressant parce que dans
les rh humains oui alors c'est
probablement ce qui manque depuis le
début c'est provenance qui manque dans
ce système un peu plus d'humains -2
réglementaire - deux décrets et plus les
plus humains aujourd'hui les chefs
d'établissements n'ont strictement aucun
pouvoir enfin concernant le rh les
enseignants sont viennent parce qu'ils
ont réussi un concours ils ont un
certain nombre de points liés à leur âge
le fait qu'ils ont un certain nombre
d'enfants un enfant handicapé qui sont
mariées pas marié etc et puis et puis
c'est tout quoi donc sinon il n'y a pas
de rh en tout cas proche du terrain la
rh est complètement centralisée au
niveau c'est vraiment haussé le niveau
central qui décide de tout
emmanuel may cry tout très régulièrement
question de effectivement donner plus
d'autonomie plus de pouvoir aux chefs
d'établissement que ce soit dans celle
des professeurs de les proviseurs des
principaux et les directeurs d'école on
en est quand même très très loin il ya
cette fameuse expérience qui était
annoncé par emmanuel macron à marseille
où il est indiqué que les directeurs
d'école pourrait avoir leur mot à dire
sur le recrutement de certains
enseignants ça concernerait 50 écoles
attention - enfin voyez on est vraiment
dans l'expérimentation tondent a poussé
les hauts cris ans dans le milieu
syndical et éducatif en disant que
c'était la boîte de pandore etc pour
l'instant on est quand même dans quelque
chose de quatre et ça veut dire être
hyper expérimental est généralement tout
tout ce qui concerne à c'est tout ce qui
pourrait concerner cette augmentation de
pouvoir entre guillemets pierrard chic
des chefs d'établissement finalement
elle reste toujours à la portion congrue
par exemple on parle très régulièrement
des postes à profil à la cour des
comptes systématiquement faudrait alors
les postes à profil c'est bon les chefs
d'établissement ne peuvent pas recruter
d'enseignants mais on va leur fini vont
pouvoir quand même créé des petits
postes alors par exemple un prof qui
enseignerait qui viendrait de
l'enseignement primaire un instituteur
professeur des écoles mais qui pourrait
enseigner en sixième il ferait la
transition cm2 6e ça peut être
intéressant donc ça n'existe pas on va
créer un poste à profil est comme ça on
va on va recruter la personne on va le
ramasser les recevoir en entretien c'est
le chef d'établissement qui va décider
mais ça l'année dernière c'était 200
postes voyez si on a promis un
enseignant à 800000 donc pour ça pour
dire qu'on est tous les ans lors de
l'expérimentation sophie vit méditer sur
ce pouvoir supplémentaire qu'on pourrait
donner au sein d'établissements pourquoi
ça coince pourquoi les pourquoi vous
dites
imaginons ce que ça pourrait donner dans
un collège dans un lycée un chef
d'établissement qui pourrait recruter
des enseignants comment un chef
d'établissement c'est à dire une perdant
je parle de nous mais on semble pas
seulement du recrutement le côté air à
charge et aussi d'évaluer les profs de
de les faire progresser en fonction de
yens sur leurs résultats en fonction de
leur qualité par des leurs mérites il ya
plusieurs plusieurs dimensions par
exemple sur le recrutement mais je reste
quand même sceptique sur la capacité
d'une personne à recruter dans des
disciplines différentes c'est à dire que
est ce qu'un chef d'établissement va
être en mesure de se dire bah là je peux
évaluer je peux me dire que lui c'est un
bon prof d'espagnol parce que je sais ce
que c'est qu'être un bon prof d'espagnol
parce que je maîtrise ce que c'est
qu'être bon prof d'espagnol et en même
temps je suis capable de dire ce que
c'est qu'être un bon prof de maths srs
qu'une personne peut juger des
compétences dans chaque discipline dans
toutes les disciplines d'un collège ou
d'un lycée et d'ailleurs je crois qu'il
ya quand même un certain nombre de celle
d'ebay sur le côté rh parce que le débat
se termine ah oui bien sûr le le côté rh
après la question qui va se poser c'est
est-ce que ce côté ce lien direct entre
un chef d'établissement et un enseignant
est ce que c'est ça qui fait progresser
le service public est ce que c'est dans
un sens de service public où est-ce
qu'on est sur un lien peut-être un peu
plus de projets voire un peu plus de de
concurrence parfois entre les uns et les
autres et est ce que c'est ça l'esprit
du service public à notre sens c'est pas
forcément celui de la mise en
concurrence et à mieux appeler votre et
28 ans pour être très concret parce que
c'est vrai qu'on parle de choses
compliquées collège expérimental
clisthène à bordeaux
collège public le temps d'apprentissage
des élèves est divisé en trois un tiers
les matières générales un tiers approche
interdisciplinaire comme à l'époque de
la loire aux fondations un tiers pour
les ateliers sportifs culturels et
techniques rythme des professeurs adapté
on est plus sur les 15 heures on est
plus sur les 18 heures tout le monde
s'est mis d'accord les enseignants ont
adopté de manière volontaire 24 heures
hebdo pour tout le monde 15 ou 18 heures
de cours 13 heures de cours excusez moi
et 11 heures consacrées au travail en
équipe ça c'est intéressant oui mais
c'est le seul collège comme ça qui
fonctionne en francs alors mais vous en
avez c'est toujours le même qu'on cite
et 2 costes un peu
tendre propose un yannick jadot
notamment on en reparlera mais bon il
propose une enseigne la pratique au
collège il ya aussi fabien roussel vaki
10 32 heures à l'école voilà les 32
heures à l'école ils formation ce dans
l'établissement ça ces derniers mois
mais c'est vraiment très vite métis ya
pas que la chenille station n'a pas le
temps on n'est pas vraiment un thème de
campagne propre nom n'ont pas vraiment
il ya uniquement valérie pécresse qui a
fait de la famille vraiment un thème
majeur de sa campagne enfin qui commence
un évidement et qui parle d' une réserve
nationale par exemple de retraités pour
venir combler les absents pour venir
aussi aider aux devoirs à l'école de
façon gratuite de la primaire au lycée
et elle dit aussi qu'il faut
régionaliser les recrutements pour
éviter que les jeunes profs sont
envoyées partout voit donc il ya
quelques pistes mais c'est pas encore
vraiment le grand chantier merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à merci également
à ilana cicurel qui étaient avec nous en
duplex rappel le titre de vivre
collectif changer l'éducation c'est
possible guillaume prévost